as soon as of night we always do this
but as soon as of nighted I think God
why have I just done that s ng 38 38
guys alright mate
as always subscribe to our YouTube
channel follow us on Instagram follow us
on Twitter much ladies see the way these
silhouette matches the silhouette things
that suit lisam gust gasps gasps gasps -
gasps - gasps so much has been out for
what two three weeks now three weeks
this is the third week is the third most
been offered through flying off the
shelves skirts is flying off the shelves
I'm glad you guys are enjoying it
sorry was a little bit tired well get
into it yeah hope you guys a good mom
mmm I hope you guys are [ __ ] good
wherever you are wherever you're
listening or watching it's all love
it's all love oh god would you rather oh
well I ain't had a wood I haven't had a
would you rather in months it's like
episode three or so know what definite
wasn't three Episode two early episodes
Wow here we go top you know the drill
guys
yummy-yum hey let me get that [ __ ] that
ASMR Salop I knew you're gonna do that
monsters [ __ ] amazing to some to shop
that way that I wait - has all of them
has loads of colors he's fantastic no
spa okay seems we just do the black
things I don't [ __ ] with the black ones
that's what she said that's not what she
said that's definitely not what she said
she definitely [ __ ] with the black ones
get that's hilarious
alright would you or would you rather
would you rather this is interesting
mmm would you ever go about sex for six
months or wank non-stop into you not six
times
six bombs six months six months yeah
yeah because story time during this
coffee in nineteen it's been detrimental
for mmm-hmm and you know if I'd say
that's doing myself a confer to molest
yourself that's about to molest myself a
couple times you know there months yeah
I'm not proud of it but during the
moment it's all I can think about did I
mean whilst that wanking whilst them
climb nearly on that climax yeah
once I'm at that that cusp yeah yeah all
I can think about nothing else Matt yeah
yeah whether it's the first time the
second time or the third time in the day
nothing else man yeah as soon as of
night we always do this bras soon as of
night I think God why have I just done
that especially if it's your third or
fourth of the day some and you just like
why what there's the episode of yep you
not know episode they have you seen the
movie year one with Jack Black
no there's you want to basically Jack
Black they're like cavemen and stuff and
then they're going through like all of
history
in that religious ways so they're just
walk in and they just end up in like
Cain and Abel times the stumble across
Canaanite alright okay and obviously
Cain kills Abel appreciates how it goes
Cain kills Abel and then the when he's
doing it man kills him his brother and
they're like oh my god and then he plays
it off like he's innocent in it yes
Akane's they're like what what have I
done what have my time and he's they're
like what the [ __ ] have I done
and then Abel starts to wake up so it
was like a bizarre oh my god what the
[ __ ] he starts to wake up and Cain leaps
on him again and smashes his head in
again what the [ __ ] and then like
obviously somewhat kills him again a man
says what have I continued to do but
that's that's what that reminds ya Bank
more times in one day
and I feel the shame the cold sweat
shame when you get that post nut cold
sweat shame after you wank and you just
like wore Verdun and then you go again
the same
day what have I continued to do so there
was a day this was weeks ago probably
bout a month ago I went four times in
one day
Jesus it wasn't been red raw thumb when
I didn't notice until like I think after
the first one you know the first one's
always the best one obviously oh that's
one's the best one then I went to shower
the way I roll out of my bed after I've
not by the way it's disgraceful
it's [ __ ] disc rounds and I have to
ask why I don't really want to know
we're going because we've had this
conversation before because when i wank
and bus or not i don't just let my nut
go everywhere oh right yeah you let your
not go everywhere you're not everywhere
stomach stomach I need a boy in pole I
need a very involved for this let me put
some context today right if I haven't
awake is it's it's it is premeditated
but it's also spontaneous yeah so I
don't I don't do this whole set up like
when especially what use exactly exactly
exactly when you said when you're about
to climax nothing else matters yeah
that's like me mmm so cuz nothing else
matters
I can't donate brain process to catch
this nut in tissue
I can't donate that I need to be fully
absorbed yeah so it goes wherever it
goes and then we'll do with the mess
afterwards just like sex we'll deal with
the mess afterwards okay but right now
is it's nine is very different because I
never bash like over my duvet I'm always
in my do like in bed under cover so if
if I'm not in under covers yeah I don't
want to knock on my covers do you not
because I have to change my covers every
single time I bus or not that's not do
you know I mean this is what I do though
when so when you got there say let's say
that the whole thing's a race 100-meter
race under wanky 100 meters sprint
yeah
so when I if I'm doing an undercover
thing
yeah obviously I've done it a million
times yeah we're from doing an
undercover thing yeah I can donate brain
space up to about 70 percent yeah and in
70 meters yeah I need to be fully in
there yeah so when I get to meet 70
meters I fling the covers back I
literally do when I'm there stroking
fling the covers back and then the last
day is an all-out sprint the last day is
an all-out sprint and that's when ya got
going on covers it'll go to nothing now
if I might stay on abdomen wilfer me
that's the culture shame it's the cold
sweat of shame i bash and I'm not in my
hand
yuck and then I fling off my duvet on my
other hand and because it's like this
that's back to roll out of bed and
literally have to roll out of there no
that's what's it that sounds worse to me
I'm not nothing in my hand when it's on
your stomach it's just like I don't feel
like it yeah if it's on my stomach
you're not Yap stomachs that's what you
do when you're when you're missionary
and you pull out you not in a stomach oh
yeah on my own stomach sorry for
catching it rolling out and going to the
I don't have the brain space to catch
I'm not catching it I can't catch it
I'm just bashing firm I know what you
mean there because me catching it
literally takes like a second away from
the pause yeah yeah
[ __ ] yes then where you're coming from
but long story short bashful times my
dick swallow up swelled up I swallow it
swallow up on one side it was yeah it's
weird for a day scare you
the life out I'm gonna see that before
I've never seen it before
do you know I mean I've never seen it
before yeah it's like let's say this is
not all like like this it was like oh I
know how to explain it it was like a
capital P there was a lump on this I was
weird yuck
and that scared me for a whole day Wow a
whole day
I was like and they just subsided they
just went back to normal then I'm like
this is the right sequence of Bashan
four times a day I was like FRA Wiley's
I know now didn't I mean it was finally
don't know I know yeah three three and
then we'll take a break take it easy
ya know if I don't fall I'm injured
muscle when I was a kid that's all I did
what like yeah I think my record was
like seven or eight a day in a day he's
sure positive
I'm positive I'm not after like yeah but
it was like nothing it was like a drip
it would just it would just whip out
just Falls up the tip like a tear you
just bleed out and then just say bleed
out bro that was yeah this was tough
time oh my days but yeah man like that
was I don't know man but yeah because of
that though I've trained myself so now
if I want you to do for ya I could hold
for I could hold for easily I think that
time was the first time I done for yes I
would rather not have sex for six months
then - what do you say how many times so
six months no six
yeah bash into not six times cuz like
that's nothing you just have to keep
going into you get another hard-on and
then you know again and then go into yet
another hardened and not again six
months because that is painful I think
it'll be a nightmare people people are
probably thinking why the [ __ ] would you
choose that why'd you choose no sex with
since most you're an idiot
you've got bashed four times a day I'd
choose six years before doing that to
you man have not bashed four times in
one day before or like in a short space
of time that's why you think it is he
isn't tamp you would nut blood if you
try to do that that's disgusting
you would not blood sure for sure on the
sick of Nightmare blood it's coming out
that's the nightmare the reason I
thought about it is because I thought
obviously doesn't nightmare but also
there's been time have you ever had time
were you being [ __ ] and you not
obviously hmm this is an inciting so you
didn't pull out yeah you're not it
inside yeah but for some reason
you've still got sent me afterwards yeah
yeah you just got any like okay yeah
like don't move that's not a titanium
yeah I'm not sure what's going on but
yeah yeah don't disturb him just just
see if he wants to carry on and then
randomly couple strokes you like oh [ __ ]
we're going straight for round two yeah
Gang Gang hmm that's why for that never
happens to me it's happened like three
times in my is always a huge rarity but
happens it does happen it doesn't make
sense I need to learn how to curate that
I need to make I need to learn how to
make it make it happen yeah I just don't
know what to do I maybe depends on a
person maybe it depends on how long you
lasted the first time maybe it probably
depends on a lot more than you think
mmm I don't know but so it sounds like
it's true also me sick and tired of how
I look I want a gym and I want steroids
but when the gym opens ain't your [ __ ]
I'll say okay I'm going on steroids big
man steroids real men steroid god oh god
are you repercussions
what on there any like side effects I'm
sure yeah that's back knee and like I
think my bull shrivel for a bit and
you're fine with that yeah yeah if I
push through them I they will probably
look even bigger I don't think you the
Lord giveth I love that beam but the big
man big man steroids mmm no needles
can't anxiety calm but big man pills
steroids yeah I'm gonna be strong mm I'm
gonna be strong and stern and manly
thick thick with quue at the end mmm
with the [ __ ] accent on it that's
like you smell thick from now on Isaac
and I've realized that like beam without
a gym is tougher that I am revisiting
like
watching my body shrivel away yeah I'm
revisiting all that anxiety not the
anxieties all the what did we call them
insecurities all the insecurities that I
used to have about my younger when I was
younger yeah and I was reliving the time
you probably don't even remember this
but these these times haunt me to this
day how I can jump from big master rates
straight away I don't know yeah probably
because I'm scared of needles but this
is backing right yet and he doesn't
scare the pen that's why we get a jail
um one time we were out it was me you
and Aaron right yeah I would think it
was a bar crawl okay it was also anytime
you need times of course yes sorry yeah
uni times yeah bar crawl it was I want
to say it was carnage I think he must
have been a carnage night or similar bar
Coral mmm so we're in casbah right young
cough it's like you know casbah ro
casbah what an establishment exactly we
were there Chinon vibe in everyone's
having a good time I think so this must
have been first or second year mmm it
was early days no and it wasn't carnage
then because you didn't do kind of still
like third year anyway it was early days
yeah as I hadn't gained an ounce of
muscle so must have been thirsty yeah
first year or second yeah yeah so Rinda
there's a group of three girls right
yeah and Aaron starts chain just being I
don't even mean hair just in Ayrshire
Enya is they were in our general area
yeah so one of them clocks you mmm and
go straight for you hmm
so now you to a chain I'm alone there's
one go left I wasn't particularly
interested yeah but for the sake of
society yeah I'm gonna talk to her right
before I had a chance to open my [ __ ]
mouth this chick is hung baracy these
chicks is gray leave me with the twig
no fam well you managed in Mike in the
laughs you know me the story I don't
think you told anyone I'm not anyone I I
was intending to take it to my grave
[ __ ] [ __ ] it we're here bro
we were there you man were having a
lavish time and she's like great leave
me with the twig the twig I'm a human
being and I was going Jim yeah I was I
was doing everything I could I was so
upset when she said that
what fam Oh being a man is hard
sorry bro is what it is sorry bro and
the reason is this is why you man on my
best friend also my worst friends yeah
because I can't talk to you about stuff
like that
in the moment yeah because this is how
this is how a reward this is how a
friendship should go yeah
and I'll tell you how our friendship
would be yeah in a real friendship yeah
in a shrewd friendship yeah that happens
yeah and then I'm like what did you say
and then you man turn around and you're
like what's going on you yeah yeah yeah
and then she's not what and I'm like big
man this thing said I'm a twig she said
leave me with the twig yeah and a new
man would be like that's [ __ ] out of
order yeah like you don't know how hard
he works like he's a nice guy
his parents parents what would have
happened is I would have been like what
did you say and the new man would have
turned out now what's going on what's
wrong and I would have been like are you
friends she said great leave me with the
twig and you melt would have loved you
would have been on the floor laughing in
my face and I'm gonna make the whole
thing worse see how the key bushnell I
just kept the L to myself and just sit
my drink alone I don't know what
happened with him yes I think they
[ __ ] off after a while but I just I
just got on with the night after that I
was so humiliated [ __ ] so no really aid
and I start thinking about every single
time like that there wasn't loads but
there was a few times I'm like rah like
a man's size is such an insecurity oh
for sure such insecure when it's like
specific times like that yeah
like the the tweet you [ __ ] sent me
the other day no I sent you that other
day when it was like the thing that she
tweeted men with big strong arms
lovestruck face mm-hmm all you other
twig armed men can evaporate evaporate
um women don't care but when it comes to
men's feelings they think they think
we're made of cement because they
clearly don't feel like you've got
feelings BAM
one Donnie one guy replied and was like
babes gyms have been closed for months
like what are we supposed to do and I
think she replied to figure it out
figure it out I was like BAM dumbfounded
what are we supposed to do we're trying
cuz no one wants to be skinny it's tough
huh it is tough out here some my gains
have been dwindling before my eyes
there's nothing I can do I've been
working out like a madman there's
nothing I can do I don't have this
efficient way to handle in before my
eyes oh it's tough I know I remember
that another time with van store shelves
mmm van store shelves so I don't know if
I've talked about here before I have I
have yeah so yeah van store shelves yeah
was a girl that I was so in love with
and she gave me the impression that she
wanted me back but she's just playing
with man she played me for by a year
plus a year plus rags and yeah we were
texting one day I might actually said
this story in here before but we were
texting one day and I was talking about
getting a sleeve on my arm
yes I know and I knew she loved mount
with tires I just knew it you've said
this story before I have like them
anyway and then for you new folk yeah
basically I said um I'm gonna get sleep
hmm
like yeah thinking she blah ah that's
[ __ ] sexy said yo cetera such issues
that now your arms a way to seem like
you won't look good
I remember screenshot listen to Arenado
you mean the gym yesterday I'm tired of
this I'm tired sick and tired of this do
you know why also that's to be fair
that's that's soapy but do you know what
also hate hmm when you know you're not
comfortable with your body you like
every every guy or every girl that
trains normally can't be comfortable
with their body right now during this
coffee nineteen and I hate it when not
necessary just in coffee nineteen by
like throughout my whole life when I'm
feel like I'm not the best I can be hmm
people say well you're not [ __ ] great
or like you are you look good today I
like no I don't know I don't know I
don't I went out I went out a few weeks
ago and I saw a few people that I am
like in a park area ever when I was
getting to the shot and then there was a
knock on come say hello cup seal I say
hello then bla bla and if someone asked
me are you doing any exercise for out
the whole quarantine thing I was like no
not really that all I've done is skip
and a few runs here and then it's like
[ __ ] you look great for real I'm
thinking are you sure
Fairplay bro to be fair I hear what
you're saying but I would rather have
that because what I got the other day
was what did I get the other day I was
taught but who was I talking to it was
either my brother or my mom or someone
like that I remember who it was I think
it was my brother
hmm and I was saying I literally said
what I said now like bro like my gains
are losing and I was like my arms are so
skinny obviously waiting for them to be
like probably tell a difference but they
didn't even say yeah you're right
but they did the thing that makes it so
much worse is that we're just like so
there's me like actually no you play me
and say brothers cover 19 things long
like I'm losing my mom supposed to go
you pay me and I'll do the reaction go
for it bro cover 19 is [ __ ] with me
man mmm so [ __ ] skinny my arms a
[ __ ] [ __ ] mm-hmm fab that's what
happened so not even like yeah you're
right
but just like mm-hmm like yeah I'm yeah
and yeah yeah is there any more they are
firm
and I was waiting for the what you mean
what you mean what you mean are like no
they're not I was waiting for them to be
like ah
they'll eat lie to me and it or change
the subject don't just blow up mm-hmm
if you change the subject I'm begging
your face by the way yeah we have to
address this why you change the subject
you can't change the subject yeah my my
buddy as of late is stressing me out so
as soon as the gyms open VAM big weights
I can't wait a con big [ __ ] way wham
wham I'm gonna take I'm gonna take it so
seriously this time because I've never
been stripped of the gym before true
I've never been astray it's my choice
not to go yeah no I don't have a choice
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've taken it for
granted
Oh 100 i moan about it sometimes taking
it so for granted I've been now moaning
about our [ __ ] gym got bothered
how dare right when there's manner here
that can't that should have apparate
apparently as far as the opposite sex is
concerned shouldn't exist and within
one's way it says good morning to
everyone over six-foot it's [ __ ] out
of order the six-foot team stressed me
out there thinks voting's really
stressed me out obviously do you do for
likes and laughs didn't blow a right but
it's like what can we do there's nothing
I can do about it there's literally
nothing never will be there never will
be anything at you know but there's
nothing else I go to a doctor and get
implants in my shins yeah and if I ask
them to break my leg and fill in the gap
yeah there's nothing I can do
baby I'll try again I've tried I've
tried I've been trained this is all they
want me to have this is the furthest I
could go I just love you and want to be
loved in return
I'm a nice guy I'm a nice guy give me a
chance and sometimes obviously I can
understand when they're [ __ ] five
foot ten when their label is when the
little chickies taught us but then rags
yeah
short man don't want you either yeah
sure I'm saying like you don't like us
we don't like you it's calm sometimes we
like you but we're so emasculated by you
that we're just gonna stay away if we
don't even stand next to you yeah
exactly so that's
hmm look for your six bus because that's
what you need in it but when you're 4 9
fem and you ask me how tall I am
and I say 5 you got app next friend that
friend you can wear the highest hills
and wardens throw me as tall as me a
tower over you tower over you and you
have the audacity and it annoys me this
is how you know it's all make-believe
because I'm five-eleven hmm so the
difference between me and 6-foot mmm is
nothing you can't tell
yeah you sound means an exercise 6 but
you can't have you can wear crepes in
your 6 box yeah these days right now
probably six foot yeah so but my resume
my resume doesn't match up
it doesn't match up it doesn't because
I've said to you before like a girl
that's five nine and the guy that's five
nine the girl always look taller bro
even though they exactly go my 5-iron
are up guys are four nine off there's
certain about abortional average
apparently exciting about their body
yeah they're long they're long they're
long it's cuz they don't hold the weight
the way the guys are more complete in it
they hold the weight in all over the
place so just look more symmetrical five
nine woman is long fam stringbean makes
no sense it's stressful man makes no
sense I need to find this steroid that
makes me taller as well and then we're
in for the money then we're for the my
old model right that will [ __ ] up your
body that will have ramifications I my
acne will be all over the gap my acne we
all over the gap will have ramifications
bro I don't I know the aesthetics will
be up it will last like a year from from
you terezi of your life and then my body
will crumble
Oh rebel little [ __ ] shrivel but I
was thinking as well obviously this is
the last thing I think I ever I don't
I'm so don't talking about coronavirus
but this is the last thing okay just to
tie it up yeah the last thing I want to
ask you mmm which is is there any
are there any points not points is there
anything that you your any takeaways
from this whole the coronavirus to the
quarantine to everything that exactly we
just survived the gym like not taking it
stuff like that is there anything else
that's made you think differently about
the world that you think your carry on
that I've learned through karate you've
learned that corner vise then the
current climate has taught you that you
think you'll take on for the rest of
your life instead of just snapping your
fingers in everything goes back to
normal or any realizations you've had
yeah for sure probably realizing that
the podcast is what I want to do for the
rest of my life I'll swear yeah okay
because and not necessarily I'm speaking
for like everyone now I feel like I've
said this before working where every pre
Corona everyone worked to make money
correct and they made money because I'm
assuming like you want to go and do
something else like you're not working
where you're working
mm-hm because you want to be there you
wanna stay there for the rest of your
life you want to move on and find
something but you have to work laughing
Joe Rogan said it on the Kevin Hart one
you've gotta work at [ __ ] places on
unnecessary [ __ ] places what places that
you're not really content or happy with
to reach the end goal but a lot of
people will go on to their day-to-day
jobs hate it quit and then lose sight of
their actual goal they want to reach do
you know I mean but to reach that goal
you still have to work a ship job to
make them money to reach that goal so
you to starting again because you have
to go to another [ __ ] job because you've
left before you can reach that goal yeah
do you not I mean so a lot of people
don't understand you have to go through
hardship to actually won't ever
understand what you want why it is you
want and understand that you have to
graph this way it's not just gonna come
some people are lucky yeah it just falls
in their lap yeah but the reality of the
world is that it never just it never
happens like that hmm and the
realization of stars in this podcast had
made me realize well first one's made me
realize how much you can do with just a
platform I know if you're a creator or
you do content how much you couldn't do
with that itself how much P how many
people you can reach with that itself
like with my day to day job yes you meet
people
day yeah but can you leave a long
lasting impression enough for them to
come back and see you yes you know I
mean they're not coming back for you
you're coming back for your
establishment yeah with this they're
coming back for us yeah there's no other
thing they're coming back for do you
know I mean because I'm so passionate
Lowe's my mind yeah yeah if it wasn't
for the fact that you said to me Oh big
man let's do this podcast let's discuss
my blah blah and I eventually said yes I
would probably if I'd never said yes I
probably still would've been home in an
hour and by all you would have dropped
it yeah I wouldn't have chase I'm the
reason why I said you see Pryor I'm so
happy that you do or like the editing
and technical side of it because I know
you don't have the time for it but you
know I will never do it do you know what
I mean yeah something I would do yeah
it's not my passion yeah because that is
your passion and then obviously once
it's all out and stuff I help out with
the the promos and blah blah it's now
become my passion yeah do you know I'm
here for sure what our passion through
this podcast stem from two different
things yeah but our goal is still the
same yeah of course and this that is my
takeaway from this Corona and I feel
like that can resonate with so many
people people because I know for a fact
millions of people work every day at a
place they don't want to work to or work
out but they're trying to get the funds
to [ __ ] off and do something else what
do what they really want to do hmm but
purely because the fact they hate their
current position right now that'd rather
sacrifice that leave and then try
something else and try something new but
you're still in that same position yeah
yes do like wait what you've let me
forward yeah that's wrong move you're
moving laterally and life waits for no
one said the more and more lateral
movements to make the order or do you
get the order or do you get the more you
think [ __ ] let me just give up anyway
yeah let me just live a normal mundane
life have kids I'm a funny and never
chase my dream yeah a hundred percent
bro that actually not a way to live your
life that is not a way to live bro that
love stuff like that because that's not
that's not okay [ __ ] you did you can't
live your life I thank you for asking
that question
no [ __ ]
you did she can't you can't live your
life like that you have to figure out
what it is you want to do and go for it
and even if you find out hour late today
that's actually up wasn't what you
wanted to do it helps you figure out
ways you want to do John Simm yeah like
I find the quickest way to find it now
what you want to do is find out first
what do you don't definitely don't want
to do yeah and like it baffles me the
complacency some people have places are
disease and just like exactly what you
said like I hate what I do but [ __ ] it
now what else am I gonna do and they
just don't take the time to figure that
out yeah they're just that [ __ ] it this
is life this is normal and people can
just firm what they see everyone else do
say it's normal and just be okay with it
that was me like before you even ever
spoke to me about this podcast I thought
to myself I'm going to be in hospitality
for the rest of my life
yeah purely because that's all I knew
once I left uni yeah yeah my adult
career started in 2013 once I graduated
enough uni all I've done it's been
hospitality from a bartender to a
manager all I've done hmm and I've
always said to you uh I want to open my
own restaurant
I've set at you many a time yeah you
have many a times and I said I don't
want to actually worry I just want to be
like the owner and be at be behind the
scenes hmm now that this has happened
yes yes is my job yes I'm doing it yeah
get me wrong cuz I've learnt how to love
it yeah but I know I guarantee no I know
I don't want to do that for the rest of
my life yeah but I was so adamant that
there was no other option that I thought
I think I forced myself to believe that
that's why I wanted to do and a lot of
people get stuck bro that's exactly the
same with before I caught that this is
what I wanted to do
luckily I knew this is what somehow I
knew this is why I want to do before we
even did it anyway oh I know that um but
when I was working his sales and because
I was alright I'd convinced myself that
I was gonna be in sales for the rest my
life yeah and I was like cool so I
probably go on to work for this kind of
company and do this kind of sales and do
this kind of stuff I make this much
money and I'd even set an earning
barrier to myself yeah and I'd only I'll
probably never earn more than this yeah
because that's what kind of sales but
that's a lot of money and I'll be
working in sales and stuff like that and
I'm like
you create this dream for yourself and
convince yourself that's your dream
that's what you should work towards and
you like when you take step back you
like that's not my dream at all and I
knew it wasn't and I managed to lie to I
managed to convince myself what I knew
it wasn't what I wanted you know what
resonated me so much I was on tick-tock
the other day and I was looking at Jason
Derulo's tick tock I don't follow him
but obviously he's like the mayor of
tick tock so I went on his tick-tock and
I went on Jenna jennifer has pronounced
a surname I went on her page and you
know they've got the bio ting were you
right wherever you want her bio said I
live life for a living and that's when I
realized that is your job unlocked the
key of life yeah her bio says I live
life for a living I had a dollar sign
next to it
dang and I'm like wow gang gang gang
gang gang gang gang that is reality
that's a dream that that's you live in I
got dream 100% that's it
I like that i as soon as I saw that I
was like wow that's good the penny the
penny drops that's good man I like that
so I can see that's very [ __ ] cool so
yeah man
I'm glad that us to take that Corona
allowed you to have that's all you sure
that's the easterlies sure about you
that reminds me
actually before I get into why is
reminds me I want to ask people that I
think I spoke to you by yesterday if
they're interested we keep getting
messages asking how started and
everything mmm so I was thinking out
doing an online course and teaching
people how to set up a podcast and get
going and stuff so if there's something
that you guys are interested in let me
know and then obviously if enough people
said they're interested then I'll just
[ __ ] do it so yeah yeah obviously let
me know for me the takeaway that I've
had is definitely agreeing with you in
terms of like my job is not why I want
to do so I said to yesterday cause II
I'm working from home yeah I'm working
from home is made me realize that like
time is everything yeah and like living
your life and doing something that
allows you to have as much time as
possible is also everything yeah and
like I'm sat on my computer or my laptop
or whatever eight hours a day and if i
won
did to debt do all the work I could
possibly do on the podcast yeah it would
not take me anywhere near eight hours
let alone everyday if I put eight hours
in a week it'll be far more than I need
and that's that's something that I want
to build as big as I can possibly get it
and I can't find 40 hours a week in
there so how are these men finding 40
hours of work for me a week and I said
when I'm sat there in the moment I just
feel like I'm burning on wasting time
yeah because I feel like I'm doing stuff
that could be done in four hours I have
to do it for a because that's the way of
the world you have to do eight hours a
day for some stupid reason and I could
be spending this time building something
or improving this or doing something and
it's stressing me out so um yeah I've
taken from Cove it I've taken that yet
that time is time is everything time
it's time is everything yeah and yet
when you have loads of time they all
went like you just use time people I
feel like people just use time
frivolously mm-hmm because I'm sorry
every day thinking why am i waste and
this is a waste of time like if they
told you like if for example my job were
like bro you've got this much work to do
you've got four hours to do it get it
done and I'll just have a bank debit
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang talk
to this person talk to that person get
this done and then done four hours I
could easily get it done yeah but
because I know I'm there all day yeah
I'm just like you putting zero effort
yeah and another thing I'm definitely
gonna take away from the co vid is ezel
is one of the biggest eyeopener's for me
is that money doesn't money means like
money means fuck-all in these situations
like you want money more than anything
and but when like a rich people and poor
people in this in that this scenario
like warranty scenario are exact same
position yeah everyone's [ __ ] no one
could do anything
so money Reid doesn't make a difference
I understand your point but
in terms of the money aspects I think
the only difference it makes is your
household is different oh of course
like the things you can do at home are
gonna be different from the things I can
do at home
yeah so like your leisure time will be
different so that could the money that
money aspect benefits them yeah that's
true that's the only thing I think about
yeah I would agree most definitely but
yeah often I think he said the only
thing I'm gonna take for I think those
the yeah I think those are the main two
takeaways for me from the covert thing
that um I might ask holing out yeah
let's go for it I like this one I like
this one I just wanna make you laugh so
am I the [ __ ] for not waking up my
girlfriend for her exam after overheard
her calling me a little [ __ ]
so my girlfriend has online summer
courses and she had an exam for one of
them this morning I usually wake her up
pretty much everything because she
sleeps through her phone alarm no matter
how long it buzzes or how many she says
she's joked around that on my Butler
before and we've in the context of a
relationship it's okay so I don't mind
obviously I want to love my partner try
and make our life easy game however last
night she was chatting with her friends
and she thought I couldn't hear she was
bragging that I'm her little [ __ ] and I
do everything for her when she tells me
to etc we hurt my feelings because they
were making comments like good put him
in his place and she was agreeing no she
specifically said yeah I'm not worried
about tomorrow because the [ __ ] will
make sure I'm up and it'll probably have
breakfast ready for me I went to bed
pretty hurt by it come on Adam before
waking her up when her alarm started to
go
I'm sure usually only gets up with
someone he physically shakes her but I
let her off her alarm and she slipped
back into sleep and I turned around I
went back to sleep too so she did
actually wake up to do her own armor she
was worried about to sleep like a
[ __ ] like that when she woke up she
was Yellin at me saying I'm an [ __ ]
and I've cost her exam and I'm a piece
of [ __ ] for what I did
she's definitely the other Oh oh that's
not even worth asking [ __ ] her and [ __ ]
her exams for our exams [ __ ] her [ __ ]
her friends bro [ __ ] all of that [ __ ]
all of that little [ __ ]
my man's a little bit so we're gonna
make me breakfast tomorrow anyway he'll
definitely I'm not worried about
tomorrow he'll wake me up and I'll
probably have breakfast ready
the little [ __ ] the [ __ ] I if I would
swing her if I heard that I'm sorting
that out then in there I'm no morning
pussyfooting around it cuz your boys are
here your girls bro bro come here we're
talking about this now bro it's done
basically the relationships not on spot
done on the spot of edges done to our
out who's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you annual exams
bro he'll probably have breakfast ready
for me oh I would want a fighter I think
some my only my only form of stepping
outside of the box is maybe he thinks
he's punching maybe he thinks like I
know she thinks I'm this type of way but
she's banging and that's the black the
best night yeah yeah yeah it must be
something because this can't be the
first instance where he's clocked that
she's spoken about him like [ __ ] can't
be well he said that she calls him
Butler and all that [ __ ] then we've got
even though it's jokes yeah like
boyfriend-girlfriend jokes it gets to
him and she does she must know it gets
to him
imagine I mean and she's calling you a
[ __ ] and all the virgins are laughing
laughing they're all laughing said yeah
put him in his place
man I'll probably have breakfast ready
our relationship is done L don't know
immediately getting out my house
immediately none of this alarm [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out you [ __ ] I'm not
waiting till the next day I'm gonna
sleep on that I gotta sleep I would be a
sleeper
I'd probably stab her once she fell
asleep I probably stab her bro that's
the next thing
thus there's I don't even know why
that's in the [ __ ] category because
of courses you Horsham on us all adios
oh she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] she's
exactly what she is boy Yemen is nothing
really else to say it's that this [ __ ]